Hear me out.
Favela city.
We all struggling.
Following our hearts, our dreams.
The problem is that to dream
we need to close our eyes.
We ain't got time to spend, bro.
In a second...
your whole life can change.
Is that what you want for your life?
Be a buffoon in front of everybody?
This will never earn you respect, son.
Respect comes from work.
Good morning, my family.
Let's go, our production never stops.
I came to get the stuff.
-The stuff.
-Yeah.
This shit is great.
And when are you gonna give me some sugar?
I'm always around.
Only 15 bucks.
It's the cops.
God showed me He has big plans for you.
If you go to jail, we're screwed, Nando.
You are not alone in this one.
Tell them I'm on it.
I'm gonna show I'm for real.
Nobody has the right to judge anybody.
Everybody deserves a second chance.
If you point the banger,
you gotta make it bang.
All you brothers here today,
my role models.
Because out there
everybody wants to kill us.
And our struggle is against the system.
We're a family.
The three of us.